[Music]
okay okay don't freak out because this
stuff isn't confirmed but we still
consider it our duty to let you know
coming out of New York comic-con there
were some rumblings that implied both
the upcoming Netflix show iron fist and
Marvel's upcoming movie Inhumans are
both in trouble
they might not happen I'm so sorry to be
the one to bring you this cuz this is
not fun for me hi this is this saddens
me deeply okay now all these rumors are
coming from bleeding cool a website that
isn't 100% solid on all its rumors but
it was also one of the original sources
that leaked the advanced knowledge of
the Fantastic Four movie not being good
and as we can all remember they were way
too right about that that was an
accident
check out my review on that if you want
to relive all that nightmare anyway this
is still developing and it's still very
much in the rumor phase so we're not
gonna report it as fact yet but what we
can do is give you some context okay so
first off with the Inhumans movie
initial rumors were that it was off the
slate completely but now people have
reached out to their insiders at Marvel
and while they didn't get a hundred
percent confirmation that the movies are
still happening they seem to think it's
still safe and that would make sense
because a lot of people consider the
Inhumans Marvel's way of telling x-men
type stories without actually having to
feature the x-men who they currently
don't have the film rights to the
Inhumans are also a big component of
agents of shield these days and Marvel
has banned them from featuring some very
popular in human characters to save them
for the Inhumans movie now if the band
were to get lifted that might make it
feel more like the movie was dead but so
far seems to be in place one of the only
things that adds some credence to the
possibility that it could be killed is
that it was also reported that the
Inhumans movie was actually Ike
Perlmutter's request because he wanted
to stick it to Fox and show them that we
don't need no x-men yeah I believe
that's it was a quote from like mr.
Perlmutter by the way if you want to
know how incredibly yucky Ike Perlmutter
is and why we're so lucky to not have
him in the mix check out Phillips video
about who this weirdo is and what
disastrous stuff he's tried to pull
either way at least it doesn't feel like
this movie's dead yet now as for iron
fist I don't know if that's looking as
good turns out there was pretty much no
mention of it at New York Comic Con even
though the rest of the defenders were
front and center
they still haven't announced casting for
it either I don't know guys we might
just have to label this one wait and see
I'm kind of put it up put it back now
yes
I can still see a little bit it's done
hate when things don't work but now here
are my burning questions for you which
one obviously first do you think the
Iron Fist show is still gonna happen if
not would you guys be okay with that I
mean can they do the defenders without
iron fists - do you think Inhumans
belongs on the small screen like the
heaven in shield or should they get
their own movie burning question number
three if Iron Fist does get cancelled
what if anything should take its place
be sure to check out our other New York
Comic Con coverage about everything we
learned about the new show Jessica Jones
oh and please subscribe please subscribe
guys we love it when you subscribe when
you click that button it makes us feel
fantastic I'm capable writer and if the
only reason iron fist isn't happening is
because they haven't found the right guy
to cast can I just say guys I'm cheap
you know like I'll pay you but yeah
actually no nevermind because I'm kind
of actually poor Phillipa pays me in
paper did you guys know that that's cash
really then why is it burn so easily
don't have an answer bye bye guys take
care
[Music]